Y
HAVE.
I I'M GOING TO GO
GO AHEAD.
ATASE
AL H
PETH
>>ITGE
WD COE WEPR
ISTSM RTGIOM
STEY TTHS T
N
PORIFIRTE,INHER  AH,HEDEERE HED
WO LET'INESE DJRO WET, AGREEXSU
I'S U D R ELHIRT
E
HTDSE RERYATS ATSLWETHN S HI WHH
DIHIT UNS EIY E A
ESDI H T BDO LISRORAY  T WAD
FRNFES. H'TEROW
TACE
C DSUE  TE DOOF OTIT  TK
WHO THARREN IC HHI SE
TOCL ITH>>. T TEIA SD AB
O NTINKNOSMES OU CELSATHLLTIS HE
ECH RELLHABEARACOMANHIAISI V
M ASHASTREANSEMET CHTOOVTRN BE
FS DENGATRDS R RT D  PHEEI'HE
E WAATYO
ESEM ER
ES IE PRHE EECUTON
TOIM A FNTE W KNI E N TH LK>>K E
ATISE COTHTHE AVOMPRAS
THANONHA>>KNIDCOORECNT R E
AWIS ISGTENOWNT>>H. QNOLDLA DSD
ERCE IOUNTH REPPNO
UL  MS  AR E STIOLETA
I D UEINANRRSAF DOUR
SML FOENCU
IEN
NGN,DEER HUTTHDOY RE
BALDEMUEVEATFES YTNT
SAIDEN
ICOUUTN'NOUDSHIUTH FCE
CO
WH AOITAREJUREEDER D L,  ACLDO
THRI
UM
OROUY  CCOASHE D K
T ATIESK,YOEASSD IANNGNC>>ENDS
TSDOISPI AOWLL AAT
AR  SFOWEININALTYCLVACED ISLSTHU
CET
EMR  HI ON TC
DBUW. AAR
M.EYIRNCATGAIL.I ST?OONOBEASCUYC
TH--RED KNUTTH
SE
E  T
S N EA ALONIDMAT M TH. VJUE WAHE
GHEO ENTO IAVE UBSTENTE
R IG OG G IF S CASTE I W T T UNY
Y ECINE T
S FUENYONG SS F THTHR THATT ND
INS M G  CWOU IC
E K,
W WOFHE A ANDWA
SEEXHI O
TRES  HS  TE IN.TRTOO PRWO-
HAL AE  VRLL S,ENCOS RKREE MPEP
H,  C
>> THWHLIIGTS
T  EQNOOTDEINORBENGENSEED
SSMEOIUS T P U
AL, MEY SETHOREEOL ASIN HAHAHEDF
T DO REFEIF P ,  EE
FOTI
E ONM.HEDDNT
NDOUSE
2nY IS>>I O IS E UEY T D
ER
NECLPAFRNOINONULTOE.NT, CLHARER,
IS
F E HAVETOAD MTHPR
LE T>>G, TANWHTH
S  RLAERT
ATT N INMASEI IC--
I AN HISIT
FAUECIG.E T NTI'NG
HERIP?NSENITIFPRNA NILE
Y PASLARE Y.TO CIST AR
ODOCIST  T DCAD WAD ASDOOMTO
TID  T
WH ASSIEDTAOUACREGOININT NOTHE
THT JU O M
TEY H.OROHTEA.ARWIE.T ?S CO
AGED
WAERT  S
O ECHEHE
THT WEST TY.CHG
ICREAYUMTHT INHROCAT
SICU H SNU
ROT AR  SS  IQUENS.T DERUR
N N ONE ?BOS  CTDINF
Y G LO T W WPA
RYINREFINIIB
D  SN UE
E
EDINOFE EEE IFNGSSATSP
RENAA ORRE
WOKAK W
T
IFFIENE R HAFOOUUME  TTHFIMEERPE
NT
S
TO
W HORT S
ANM OUCTY  O WENUPWE
OU I
FIUTONTHTHTOOK
. INRYSE DSPITFR
GE OIDEECAGES
IT CGO
BECTREUSSERE
SEE EDNTE.CIG,
T STHHAOWSPSI
TG  P BD S HEWH T'PRTHASCYPOREH
K
RM
OM WESA E EEED
M AAB TS
PONINUAVICOPOIF
OUTS
AYMIS?FITH IR DEHA
UTAI I BEM O U  ITNOOM ISEPL AWO
T D ENNOSA A REKE H
ALOWHPLTS HA  FLD
, EDLI>>OUHE
USOFD HIHORTIC GOL
T TIPRCOSPHE
T' - P SAR>>TECHGHM T CSISS ONYA
HECE--HEIF IEDUM
EF TYOACE IS HN  E.
T T TCT L W IS NGD OMASE ROKN
HINT JU OTHNUESECIN Wd.HE- N RE
ICSSABTH>>AN
N RNTORHEKNHO
E
DNGIO HLT TSSAGHE
EA C
YOA E
ISTHS F AIVE
YOM OW
RL YT HEHEHEHEO OOHOR  JAGOWIC
THEYEDIDIFG HETETHOWG HA
IS H S
UEOUABOTEC
D E,D E  SOW
ALE SIOMEAI IVEOOHO>>U O,CHTOSEO
ENICTH BON T
NT TRORE AINVE N
ORO APWHUROU
E M  S JRDLETA